hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the second match of the
Champions Chester finals Magnus Caron
versus Wesley so Magnus started the
match with a win and now well he's a
very comfortable position he can draw
his black games he can maybe play for a
win with white and everything should be
fine so let's see if Wesley will be able
to bounce back as Magnus defeated him
with the black pieces as well it's a
really wild game it will make your game
Spin but you will enjoy it so let's dive
straight into it uh Magnus with the
white pieces opens with E4 and Wesley
strikes with the Sicilian Defense we
have Knight to F3 D6 and Magnus goes for
Bishop to C4 not going for the immediate
D4 of opening the position Knight to F6
with D3 and sorry not D4 I D3 uh and
pawn to E6 we have castles and Bishop to
E7 so uh pretty close setup and already
here we have Pawn to A4 by Magnus and it
is now as of move six that we have a
completely new game so Wesley continues
by striking in the center Pawn to D5 we
usually say when black is able to do
this in the Sicilian Defense black
should be perfectly fine so let's see
Bishop to B5 check and now King to f8
Wesley really playing for a win in this
one Pawn to E5 by Magnus Knight back to
G8 look at this King to f8 and bringing
the Knight back to the starting Square
uh Pawn to A5 Magnus grabs more space on
the queen side and now Wesley tries
something very interesting he plays Pawn
to A6 and he asks Magnus what you do
with the bishop if you go to A4 I'm just
going to win the A5 Pawn but it looks
very dangerous to put the queen in front
of the Rook like that uh okay Magnus
goes uh Bishop to A4 and Wesley captures
the pawn with Queen captures on A5 so
okay his King is on f8 he had to bring
the Knight back to the starting Square
not a lot of development grabbing a pawn
with your queen uh definitely looks like
a recipe for disaster so let's see what
happens Pawn to C4 Magnus wants to open
up the center and try to attack Wesley's
King uh Pawn to D4 of course Wesley
closes it Knight B to D2 now getting the
Knight to E4 and then uh to D6 is if
possible uh Queen back to C7 we have
Knight to E4 and now Bishop to D7
attacking the bishop here Magnus trades
captures captures and now Bishop to F4
gaining more control over the D6 Square
before you plant the Knight there Pawn
to H6 and now Pawn to H4 stopping Pawn
to G5 so Pawn to G6 by Wesley and Magnus
strikes with Pawn to B4 the idea is of
course that if you capture then you
weaken the D4 pawn and then Magnus just
gets a very strong Center so that's
exactly what Wesley does and now Knight
captures on D4 we have Rook to d8 now
threatening some uh some discoveries
here but Magnus not worried about them
he just plays Queen to F3 and the reason
he's not worried about them is that if
you play Knight captures on E5 uh Knight
captures on E6 with the Royal fork and
after F captures then Bishop captures on
E5 opens up a discovery and wins the
queen on C7 so after Queen F3 King to G7
was play the Wesley s side steps all of
this and Don Magnus plans a knight on D6
looks like a wonderful Square so of
course you will have to eliminate it it
is a monster Knight captures captures
and queen back to C8 we have Rook F to
E1 H and now Knight G2 F6 Wesley finally
starts developing his King side Knight
to B3 now preparing to start advancing
those pawns and now Rook H to E8 uh we
have Bishop back to C1 Magnus of course
wants to shift the bishop over to this
diagonal and pawn to E5 Wesley closes it
Bishop to B2 and now Pawn to B6 uh we
have Pawn to G4 Magnus is all right it's
um you know not exactly what he hoped
for but he does have a Pawn on D6 he
does have a nice Bishop here and if he
can get an attack against the black king
should be fine if he can't remember he's
down a pawn because Wesley Wesley
snatched that A5 Pawn back in the
opening King to G8 uh getting uh off of
this diagonal and now Knight to D2 going
for Knight to E4 uh we have Rook to E6
Wesley trying to win another Pawn Here
and Now Magnus strikes with Pawn to G5
we have captures captures and Knight to
H7 uh and okay Magnus goes Queen to
G3 uh puts more pressure on that E5 pawn
and the Wesley finds an ingenious way of
dealing with this blocked position he's
facing he plays Rook captures on D6 and
now after Pawn to D4 Magnus says you
cannot capture as your Rook on D6 will
fall Whitley says I don't need it uh you
will have to give up the bishop here if
you want to take my Rook because this
bishop is worth a lot more so Bishop
captures we have e captures on D4 and
now Magnus brings The Rook to E7
prepares to double up on the E file and
will somehow try to go after the the
black king maybe something like King to
G2 Rook to H1 put the King on the H
Queen on the H file go after the Knight
on H7 so we have Knight to C5 here Queen
to C5 is actually deadly just attacking
the G5 pawn and The Rook on E7 so it's
the one moment that Wesley could have
used to uh really take control of the
over the game but he played Knight to C5
first and now Magnus plays Rook 8 to E1
Now The Rook is defended so you don't
have time for this uh and Rook to f8 now
bringing a Defender to the F7 Pawn uh
Knight Knight to f8 was probably a
little bit more correct we have Queen to
H4 now Magnus wants to bring a rook
behind the queen and then check made
Wesley's King uh we have Pawn to B3 and
now King to G2 the correct way to do it
is F4 F4 because you the black queen
doesn't have any checks towards the
white king and now Rook to E2 followed
by Rook to H2 and then you go after the
Knight so this is the winning idea but
Magnus play King to G2 and now Wesley
finds the correct move of course not
check uh because then just Pawn to F3 uh
the correct idea is Queen to F5 and now
you don't have time to uh to go for Rook
to H1 uh of course if you go for Rook to
H1 here then just Queen captures on G5
with check trades off the uh the Queens
so Rook seven to E5 attacks the queen
and defends the pawn here Queen back to
D7 and now Rook again back to D5 now the
real way to do it is Rook E7 Queen back
and now Pawn to F4 you still have time
for this but Magnus went for Rook to D5
Queen to C7 and now Rook to H1 going
after the Knight here but the reason
Wesley put the queen on the seventh rank
is that so he can advance the F Pawn and
we said you know you should never play
F6 even when it's winning here it's the
only move for Wesley to survive the
attack H and now Magnus goes for Knight
to E4 it looks like uh definitely the
move but Wesley plays F captures on G5
and now attacks the queen here and
probably best and still maybe giving
Magnus some chances is Queen to H6 but
he goes for Knight captures on G5 uh and
now we have Knight to D3 H and this
again gives Magnus a winning position uh
the the real idea you want to play here
and I will show it because it's really
awesome is Knight captures and G5 Rook
captures and G5 looks like black is
getting destroyed here but look at this
queen G7 and after Queen to G4 going for
Rook captures on G6 there's Knight to D3
the move that Wesley played only like
five moves too early and now if Rook
captures of course Knight to F4 with
check ends the game H you will have to
capture then Queen captures with check
and if you play this then just captures
captures and uh Black's pass pawns are
of course Very Much winning here uh but
after night captur on G5 Knight to D3
was played by Wesley and now again it's
Magnus who's winning Knight captures on
H7 is enough to win he goes for Knight
to A6 for the uh Fork here attacks the
rook and the queen because they are all
playing on increment here you can see
they both have 7 seconds on the clock uh
and now Queen to F7 and there is only
one winning move for Magnus here and
that is Knight captures on f8 but he
doesn't play it he plays Queen captures
an H7 with check which wins him a piece
uh but um he disregards the the the
power of the past pawns so Wesley has to
trade here we have captures captures
King captures and now Knight captures
even comes with check but look at this
King to G8 uh and now even though Magnus
is up a full Rook the pass pawns are
just too powerful we have Rook to D6
Magnus realizes it and says okay you
take my knight I want to go after your
pawns but Wesley says Nope Pawn to B2
he's not interested in the knight uh
Rook captures on B6 but now Pawn to A5
and with the B2 Pawn protected it's
merely matter of A4 A3 A2 and A1 that's
all there is so Magnus will try to
defend Rook to B3 A4 Wesley not
interested in anything here he just
wants to advance that pawn all the way
to A2 Pawn to A3 and now Knight to E6
with a discovery but now King to F7 and
Knight to G5 with check King to G7 and
Rook to B7 with check and if the king
comes to H6 then you are sort of able to
box the king in for example King H6
you're going to go here and if the King
goes here you can even deliver some Rook
to B5 check maybe even Checkmate the
black king but of course Wesley not
interested he goes back and now of
course there are no more ideas here
Magnus does find one last trick in the
position he plays Knight to E4 Pawn to
A2 and now Knight to F6 with check King
to f8 and now he plays Rook to D7 it's a
a very well-known um uh three-fold
repetition setup and of course Magnus is
hoping for Wesley to play Pawn to A1 uh
and maybe he played it maybe he played
Pawn to B1 Maybe he played something
else what would you play here feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only winning idea for Wesley while I
give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on not
being Hasty with the pawns and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Knight to F4 with check and not
for the sake of giving a check but for
the sake of reaching the A5 H5 Square
that's the way to do do it uh H Knight
to F4 check was played and uh yeah for
those of you who don't trust me like if
you play B1 Queen here then you just
deliver a check and there's no way to
avoid the repetition uh King here Knight
to F6 check uh forces the king back King
f8 another check if you go to G8 another
check now you cannot go here because
Rook to H7 is Checkmate so you have to
go back and then another check and then
another and then another doesn't matter
how many queens black has so that's why
Knight to F4 check King F3 Knight to H5
uh and it was in this position move 56
that Magnus Carlson resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here I
think Wesley uh wesle even sort of uh
you know said okay I'm losing this one
as well but then he found the the
winning idea I mean it was absolutely
crazy they were both playing the last 20
moves basically on seconds but yeah
Magnus managed to find one last trick
but Wesley does not fall for it he takes
Magnus down and now the point is of
course that once you deliver a check
there's no Knight back to F6 six that's
the idea behind Knight F4 check and
Knight to H5 uh it was um enough and
Wesley takes down Magnus with the black
pieces in game two of their Champions
Chester finals second match uh so two
more games remaining will Wesley take
the win in this match and force the
third match uh we'll see or will Magnus
just take the the win or the draw in the
second match as well uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it really
a wild one I would like to thank Robert
arthon Sam John toris Farm the Night
Before Christmas good luck school finals
CV and Benjamin hyberger for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes H so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day